amerika hat gewählt aber wir wissen
nicht wer der präsident ist der
amtierende präsident donald trump der
weiß es schon er hat gewonnen sagte er
klar
und ginge es nach ihm könnte die
auszählung der stimmen in den umkämpften
staaten jetzt eingestellt werden
[Applaus]
er will sogar vor das oberste gericht
gehen um die auszählung zu unterbinden
das ist ungefähr so als wären wir in der
80 minute eines fußballspiels sie eine
mannschaft führt 1 0 und dann sagt sie
wir können jetzt aufhören es lang wir
haben gewonnen und wir brauchen nicht
bis zum ende spielen
das ist unerhört das wirft ein schräges
licht auf sein demokratieverständnis er
kann gewinnen
er wird vielleicht sogar gewinnen das
weiß man nicht aber jetzt schon zu sagen
mitten während der auszählung in staaten
wie pennsylvania wisconsin und michigan
georgia und north carolina allesamt
umkämpft das brauchen wir nicht mehr zu
tun er habe gewonnen ist wirklich ein
schlechter dienst an der amerikanischen
demokratie
das wird dazu führen dass sind die
kommentatoren sich einigt und sie haben
in dem punkt recht
das trägt dazu bei den glauben in die
amerikanischen demokratie in den
wahlprozess zu unterminieren
der start der besonders umkämpft ist auf
denen es wahrscheinlich auch den
allerletzten wähler noch ankommen wird
das pennsylvania
dort haben wir uns umgehört denn hier
ist quentin den pennsylvania an der
geburtstag von joe biden aber auch
rampen hier gibt es hier
menge ich habe den abend mit ein paar
von ihnen verbrachten am tag war ich
kurz mit denen unterwegs sind mir so
kleinen corsa mit den trucks und den
flaggen am auto gemacht und sind hier
durch die stadt gefahren haben um gehupt
und stimmung gemacht für tram
abends fand wieder zusammen bei hot dogs
wein und bier gesessen und haben sich
das wahlergebnis angeguckt richtige
siegel stimmung ist nicht aufgekommen da
wurde noch skeptisch erstmal der abend
begonnen um so später ist dann der abend
voranging umso besser wurde die stimmung
aber trotzdem ganz am ende wieder ganz
richtig reichen wird es wahrscheinlich
noch nicht
es könnte noch ein paar tage dauern bis
pennsylvania eine entscheidende staaten
hier wirklich ein ergebnis liefert wenn
auch manche träume für die demokraten
geplatzt sind sie haben das
repräsentantenhauses erfolgreich
verteidigt es ist unklar ob sie eine
mehrheit im senat errungen werden
was ist aber mit dem großen preis mit
dem weißen haus joe biden
der 77 jahre alte kandidat ist
zuversichtlich dass er am ende die nase
vorn haben wird
warum auch der aussöhnungsprozess so
kompliziert ist unabhängig von den
verschiedenen wahlgesetzen ist einfach
die schiere zahl der wähler der früh
wähler der briefwähler und der wähler am
hauptaltar cas wird eine rekord
wahlbeteiligung erwartet und bevor noch
am dienstag in den vereinigten staaten
die ersten wahllokale aufgemacht hatten
haben bereits mehr als 100 millionen
wähler ihre stimme abgegeben als früh
wähler oder als früher als briefwähler
das ist beispiellos und zeigt wie hoch
das glück wie stark und wie hoch die
politische temperatur in dem land ist
und wie es gross dass die
wählermobilisierung mobilisiert haben
sie beide
aber vielleicht dort nicht fahren sogar
noch etwas mehr
dort jedenfalls wo es darauf ankommt